Shakespeare had written of course very famously that all the world's a stage
right? And that's really the kind of picture of metaphor that Newton has in mind throughout his greatest work "The Principia"
The planets will move around, the comets will orbit the sun, the apples will fall, and all that happens, all that action
Takes place on a kind of perfectly rigid, unchanging stage. That stage is then space and time for Newton
So Newton says very famously space and time are each absolute. They flow without
Compromise, there's nothing that happens on that stage is going to affect the stage itself
They're not actors in the drama
Newton's view of time is
the what I would call the everyday notion of time that we
That we grow up with, that we become familiar with in our everyday lives: the notion that time is universal
It's the same for everyone,
Everywhere no matter what they're doing,  that it ticks away at a constant rate and time is passing
equally and
exactly the same for everyone no matter what they're doing and
All of our everyday experience points to this being the correct notion of time
And we come to, to, Einstein and especially with his general theory of relativity
his theory of Gravity
Space and time were their union into space time now has become an actor in the play
it's not sort of set off apart from the other things like the planets whizzing around or comets or apples
It's now part of that story so that the other actors say large
masses like the Sun can actually have an impact that can affect the
shape of space the flow of time in its vicinity and vice versa
So they become part of the kind of stage play not set off
So Newton had said time and space were first of all separate from each other and were sort of absolute apart
Distinct and Einstein starts folding them in to the kind of larger drama
In Einstein's theory of gravity time, becomes personal
So the time that elapses for me is entirely personal to me the time
elapses for anyone is entirely personal to them and
the way that time
Elapses, the way that time flows for an individual is
Completely dependent on where they are and what they're doing
So if all the world's a stage, then the structure of that stage is the structure of space-time this entity that that Einstein introduced